I don't watch it okay so Rosie O'Donnell
says she doesn't watch the view but she
does seem to have some thoughts on it
here's what she said about current
co-host megan mccain on Bravo's watch
what happens live i think she's in a
difficult position and she's being the
conservative voice on the show truck
yeah trying to do that while grieving
you know right it was very very tight
with her father and he had been dying
for a while and I think she's we've
watched her daily you know try to grieve
and get through it's not really that
easy yeah I do have some compassion for
her although I wish she wouldn't be mean
to Joy Behar who is you know like a
living legend and should be respected
for no other reason than she's the elder
statesman in the room that exchange went
down at just last week on the ABC talker
though both joy and Megan said using the
B word was no big deal for them a
friendly argument is a great thing on
the show moving back to Rosie she also
opened up about the state of her
relationship with Whoopi Goldberg which
was described as pretty contentious in
the view tell all ladies who punch
Rosie is very open about the fact that
she and Whoopi had a toxic relationship
on the show I'm always gonna respect her
I'm always gonna look up to where she
was somebody who was inspirational in my
career and you know you like to keep
those people in a place of reverence if
you can and that's what I'm hoping to do
Rosie who gave an interview for the book
has been pretty public about her disdain
for it she's always been candid and
honest and open and raw as an interview
subject and I think I'll just leave it
at that
I appreciate that she took the time to
answer my questions she specifically
spoken out about how her comments about
Elisabeth Hasselbeck were taken out of
context Rosie said she and her on-air
foe had crushes on each other which did
not sit well with Elisabeth Rosie I
think it was disturbing to read those
things and it was offensive to me did
you think Elizabeth took your comments
in that book out of context I hear ya
yeah yeah come on she knows too that's
the thing is that she knows she knows
exactly what I'm talking about
[Music]
[Applause]